il fallait bravé la pluie la boue ce
dimanche lors de la 11e édition de l'eau
castor cette traditionnelle course
d'orientation organisée par le club de
guyancourt cette année les circuits
étaient très technique la pluie
augmentant la difficulté le dimanche 7
196 participants armés de leurs cartes
étaient au départ de la course pédestre
au total plus de mille concurrents
étaient présents sur tout le week-end le
vainqueur juste rimbaud a mis sa carte
dans le bon sens et a bouclé le parcours
de 22 km en deux heures et six minutes
sur la version famille la mini aux
castors les parents n'étaient pas de
trop pour résoudre les énigmes du
parcours